baby backs
I wish you achieve my powers will become
yours
[Applause]
[Music]
right what are your superpowers simmer
for hours dude I don't even know how to
pee in this thing you totally did the
opposite of what a superhero supposed to
do how old are you basically 15
[Music]
yeah you will let the computer to bus
and almost kill these people and then I
caught it
hey everybody it's Charlie we got a
bunch of new Shazam footage to break
down pull the real Slim Shady please
stand up I like that there's also sort
of a buried foreshadowing fight with dr.
sivana
and eventually Black Adam in that Slim
Shady song there's a lot more Justice
League jokes and references so we got to
break it down there's a new round of
that imax ticket giveaway - all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite joke from the
trailer on the video you get a whole
bunch more of his fight with dr. sivana
you get a little bit more of their
montage of him testing their powers and
more of the Shazam family learning that
Billy has powers the joke about the
Eminem song real Slim Shady is just him
trying to pick a special superhero name
for himself his name is Captain Sparkle
fingers no that's not that's not it
that's not my name totally not my name
he does call himself Shazam but it just
seems like at this point in the movie
Billy hasn't completely embraced the
persona yet like he keeps saying the
word Shazam to activate his powers over
whatever reason it just hasn't clicked
in his brain that that's what he should
call himself because technically when he
meets the wizard this is the wizard
Shazam that passes his powers on to him
so he's taking his place he should also
take his name eventually I haven't
listened to that song and forever but
the Easter Egg and their foreshadowing
his coming fight with dr. Siobhan and
then eventually Black Adam is that the
successor song to the real Slim Shady is
will the real Slim Shady please stand up
which is all about calling out
pretenders to his name so you could look
at it as if dr. sivana is a pretender to
the name Shazam because he also has the
powers of Shazam he was once a candidate
but Billy is meant to be the real
successor he's supposed to be quote
unquote the real Slim Shady but that's
not even the beginning of it because
that metaphor also works with Black Adam
because Black Adam also says the power
word Shazam to activate his power so
he's sort of a pretender in a way or he
views Billy as a pretender eventually
when they'll face off at some point in
the future we don't know when that movie
is gonna happen but supposedly the Black
Adam movie will be self-contained in the
way that the Shazam movie is relatively
self-contained there's not gonna be a
Black Adam really big presence in this
film maybe post-credits scene I've
already talked about post
scene theories for the Shazam movie
probably something foreshadowing black
Adam coming because that will be the
next Shazam universe movie but
supposedly Billy Batson won't be a big
part of that and if they face off
against each other it would be like a
third film down the road or a crossover
with someone else like Superman
hopefully we'll see Henry Cavill come
back sometime soon hopefully that
explains a little bit about what's going
on with Black Adam inside this universe
he's still very much a character very
much around very much a big bad guy but
he won't actually be fighting Shazam in
a movie for quite a while he hit the
same version of him going to get his
powers say my name what are you for real
like he just doesn't totally believe but
you see him walk into the cave this is
also a mirror scene for the doctor
sivana flashback when he was a little
kid as a candidate walking into the cave
to get the Wizards powers the difference
in Billy shot is that it sort of blocks
the seven deadly sins because they are
the MacGuffin of the movie even though
it's like a really big dangerous thing
that can't be let out the real villain
is dr. sivana he's the one that it will
eventually probably released the seven
deadly sins there's a bunch of jokes
about merch in this trailer but also in
real life there's been a bunch of Shazam
merchandise for the movie with the
Shazam family the other kids in their
special costumes when they get powers
with different members of the seven
deadly sins so it just seems like at
some point towards the very end of the
movie like when they're having their big
fight here you see dr. sivana holding
the Wizards staff something about this
last big bite involves Billy in the
Shazam family fighting the seven deadly
sins you get a much longer version of
the montage where they're testing his
powers certificate of authenticity like
they're videotaping it like we have
evidence here this is for real super
strength is strength of Hercules
electricity manipulation is power of
Zeus hyper speed is speed of mercury
when it looks like he's trying to stop
some mugger or somebody that these Peaks
is hurting someone in the park here
there's a much longer version of that
convenience store scene where he's
trying to stop the muggers and buy the
beer and he gets captain Sparkle fingers
then you finally see dr. sivana walk in
and this is actually after the scene at
the end of the trailer where he saves
the bus you actually get a little more
dialogue from him too he calls him out
chosen one and then blasts the police
with the magical lightning before they
start beating the hell out of each other
I think the scene where Freddy says you
did the opposite of what a superhero
would do comes after he saves the bus
like he's trying to take him to task for
like dude yeah it's really cool that you
saved it but you
created this accident you hear the
dialogue for Mary Marvel saying you're
that hero then you see the rest of the
Shazam family in their house walk up and
try to ask Billy about what's going on
with this special new superhero that's
been flying around this is Mary Marvel
obviously this is Darla this is Eugene
and this is Pedro you get a bunch more
scenes of him fighting dr. sivana while
they're flying through the air chasing
each other this might be while they're
heading back to the rock of eternity
because it was that scene in the other
trailer where you see the portal open up
midair between these two giant towers
you've been all the footage we've seen
in the sequence of events pretty sure
that dr. sivana with the Wizards staff
here when they're fighting in the
Carnival is right towards the end of the
film and he uses the staff to release
the seven deadly sins from the rock of
eternity you get the really funny scene
with them in the toy store with all the
Justice League toys he picks up the
Batman toy that says I'm Batman it
throws it up get him Batman
the thing is you actually only see a
couple of the characters here like
there's no flash or Aquaman toys visible
they're probably just in the background
behind him or something like that
there's a bunch of cyborg toys
interestingly enough it's weird that you
would see a bunch of cyborg toys on the
Shelf here like they're flying off the
shelves or something without seeing
flash toys or Aquaman stuff next to it
most of these actually do look like
they're real toys that you could go out
and buy today just actual merch that
they pulled out of DC Direct the design
of the Batman toys looks a little bit
like Batman the Animated Series but you
see the Man of Steel logo and all the
Superman merch in the background the
Superman costumes there's the Wonder
Woman skateboards there's a bunch of
Wonder Woman figures over on the left
side there's a bunch of Wonder Woman
dolls on the right side I think some of
this is a joke on how popular the
characters are now like the characters
like Batman Wonder Woman Superman are
way more popular than the other Justice
League characters so you see way more of
their merch particularly Wonder Woman
just winking it the fact that her movie
just blew up and did super huge there's
also some Tigers in the background
that's just a reference to tawny the
tiger from the Shazam comics love that
when the frame pans out a little bit in
the middle of this fight get him Batman
you actually just see regular shoppers
behind him like they have no idea what's
going on like why is this dude in a cape
in a costume fighting this of the guy
with Batman toys then there's the same
scene of dr. sivana at the Shazam
family's home intimidating Billy and the
rest of the family learning how old he
really is I'm basically like 15 years
old I'm you know just a little kid you
finally get the longer version of that
bus safe so you actually see how it
winds out crashing he's just why he's
for cash knee throws lightning
accidentally hits the bust and it flies
off so yes is a funny moment but it's
also just a way in this trailer for them
to show you what all his different
abilities look like how he moves how
strong he is
for the most part on screen visually he
just meant to look about as strong as
Superman would when he's doing something
like this so the bus safe is sort of a
wink at the car safe from the classic
Superman comics they also did that
during Brandon Ralph Superman there was
like a scene meant to mirror the
original action comics save where he's
grabbing the car and just putting it
down safely then you get that big
Superman joke at the end where he says
you can leap tall buildings in a single
bound then separately he tries to jump
up really hard screams and excitement
but actually bust through that office
window sorry so sorry so just a better
showcase of his abilities as powers and
sort of what his fight against dr.
sivana is like and obviously they tuned
up a lot of the special effects in this
that's one of the reasons why you don't
see a lot of trailers early on is
because they're still polishing special
effects and they want to give you a
couple different shots so like all this
bus stuff probably wasn't ready when
they released the previous trailers
which is why it took so long to get this
trailer but just a reminder that this is
taking place in Philadelphia and present
day after the events of Justice League
that's why the Justice League merch is
in there and it's so popular like
they've been watching these superheroes
on the news for a long time now I know
everybody's wondering about what's gonna
happen with Henry Cavill and the next
version of Batman but clearly they still
exist in or around and present day
otherwise they would not be selling
merch for all these toys but you do have
to wonder what the company is that's
selling this because I'm sure the comic
books exist in this world but I don't
know if they've created comic books
based on the Justice League heroes yet
the way they explain comic books about
the characters on the flash TV show is
is that the comic books are like flash
comics inspired by the life of Barry
Allen in the future so at some point in
the future of Earth one in the DC TV
universe DC comics is created and they
create comics based on Barry Allen's
adventures but all the comic book Easter
eggs they use are for like Geoff Johns
and Mark Waid era comics so it's sort of
this mobius strip of references whereby
comics inspire movies movies borrow
Easter eggs and say that the comics are
inspired by the movies themselves so it
becomes a really meta Easter egg I'm
sure it'll probably be a similar
situation in this universe
where eventually people are inspired by
a Superman Batman Wonder Woman's actions
the flash all these characters to create
a comic book company in write stories
based on their adventures so that
eventually we may see like a version of
a comic book from DC Comics show up in a
movie right now we don't have a timeline
on the first trailer for Wonder Woman
1984 normally I would say they'd
released the first teaser with Shazam
when it drops in theaters but because
Wonder Woman 1984 isn't coming out till
summer 2020 next summer they might not
release the first trailer till Comic Con
later in July this year which seems like
a better date for them just because they
have more eyeballs all at the same place
at the same time but I'm also hoping
that by the end of this summer when we
start getting all that footage they'll
also tell us what's going on with the
flash movie because they said that
they're currently rewriting it right now
I already posted that Ezra Miller video
with him explaining what it's going to
be so I'll link that at the end of this
because he is pretty candid about the
plot and the mechanics of how it's going
to work but we'll also probably find out
who's the new Batman is going to be in
Matt Reeves Batman movie so don't worry
whole bunch of DC news will be coming at
Comic Con later this summer because all
the big changes they've been making my
Captain Marvel review will be posting
tomorrow sometime I don't know what time
it's going to be but as long as you have
alerts enable for my channel you'll see
it that's coming out this Friday I'll do
Easter eggs for all that stuff
there's also a big new Game of Thrones
info bomb that video should be up in the
next couple of hours so look out for
that while you wait for everything click
here to watch
Azra Miller explain what the flash movie
is going to be and click here for my
non-spoilery early Captain Marvel review
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]